take it are like not but like steamed
and fluffy soft delicious everyone chef
Joe sass go here I'm a chef normally I
am traveling the world hosting pop-up
dinners and teaching pasta classes but
nowadays I'm in a social distancing
doing all my cooking from home and
teaching my lessons virtually today
working from home in my home kitchen
banking cacio e pepe steam buns which is
inspired by a traditional bow cacio e
pepe meaning cheese and pepper in
italian bring my Italian roots into this
I have all my ingredients here and we're
ready to get started
[Music]
salt sugar yeast into the milk and cream
1/8 room temperature stir it all
together and this is instant yeast since
it's instant I can use it right away all
right we're gonna mix our wet
ingredients into the dry ingredients
using a stand mixer if you don't have a
stand mixer you can do this all by hand
just going to take a little longer into
the mixer for about 15 to 18 minutes
[Applause]
so we've been mixing for six minutes
here I always like to come in scrape
things down with a pastry card make sure
everything's getting mixed up evenly I
learned out about 18 minutes here on our
dough things are looking nice and smooth
the bowl is clean supple we're going to
let the dough rest now I have a greased
bowl here just gonna plop that down
inside I like to use a reusable shower
cap as my lid saving plastic where I can
they'll get plenty of uses out of this
I'm gonna set it someplace warm till
it's about doubled in size in the
meantime I'll start my cheese filling
all right I have all these different
cheeses in all different sizes and
shapes because as the cheese melts I
want all different degrees of cheesiness
and melt enos we're going for the
ultimate cheese pull here in these cacio
Pepe buns we're gonna put all of this
back into the stand mixer here while the
dough is resting and then using the
paddle attachment this time we're just
gonna whip it all together
[Music]
finally have our peppercorn blend
everybody going into the party alright
last but not least a little pinch of
salt we'll turn the mixer on low speed
so you can get covered in cheese we're
just gonna whip this till it all comes
together I had our cheese mix it's
complete this stuff is addictive on its
own I'm gonna put it in a container here
and wait for my buns to finish proofing
it's been two hours
my dough is doubled in size it's time to
punch it down and then we're gonna
portion these buns
the reason we're punching down our dough
is to de gas it so it has the
opportunity to then rise again once
they're all portions I'm gonna portion
this out into 70 gram buns you don't
have to weigh them we're gonna get about
16 buns out of this whole recipe here so
we have all of our buns portioned time
to roll them into these beautiful nice
little rounds we're gonna do that by
rolling the meanest circle on the
surface of the table laying the
attention of the dough kind of stretch
itself underneath so we have this nice
smooth round and everything's tucked up
underneath I like to keep these under a
damp towel while I get my filling ready
to stuff so while my buns are resting
I'm gonna make a little garlic butter to
brush on top of the buns right when they
come out of a steamer basket while
piping hot and cheesy I'm gonna chop up
a little parsley here this is gonna go
into my garlic butter I'm gonna take my
butter and heat it up here with a little
bit of microplaned garlic in it I got my
chopped parsley
now my favorite part the cheese so I'm
using a scooper here to a portion of the
cheese into my buns you want to push out
the edges almost like you're making a
top hat and leave a lot of mass here in
the center I'm gonna pick it up push the
center down a little bit like so and
that's gonna be my little pocket landing
zone for my cheese that's where the
speaker comes in I like to think more
cheese is more better and then pushing
your cheese filling into the bun pulling
up your edges and start to seal
everything like something alright it's
been out 40 minutes now our buttons have
proofed again your puffy they're perfect
they're ready to steam I'm using the
steamer basket setup if you don't have a
bamboo steamer you can use a vegetable
steamer whatever you got is all about
being resourceful today so I got a
little bit of parchment down on the
bottom that's gonna prevent sticking and
help block some of that steam I'm gonna
put the top on and then drop these
[Music]
into the steamer and these are gonna
steam for about five to ten minutes and
it's been ten minutes we're gonna check
on our buns be mindful of the steam
steam is hot oh those are looking great
check that out we just made steamed buns
guys I have my garlic and parsley butter
here and we're just gonna brush this on
top of the buns and get that buttery
garlic goodness on everything all right
here it is we've made it to the end our
Khatri Oh Pepe steamed buns brushed with
garlic butter I can't wait to dig in
here let's hope for this ultimate cheese
pull
fingers crossed oh man
let's try this out
take a garlic knot but like steamed and
fluffy soft delicious nice squishy dis
to it black pepper the whole blend of
cheeses I am so happy with this there's
nothing else that you need thanks
everyone for joining me if you guys
enjoyed this video please check out some
of my other BuzzFeed tasty videos on
YouTube or follow me along on instagram
at chef Joe DASCO
oh oh yes
[Music]